[Música]
vengo a hablar un poquito de mí primero
y les cuento que yo desde muy chica
siempre supe que quise pasar el resto de
mi vida rodeada de libros fue muy claro
para mí o sea tuve como una señal con mi
primer libro y asia ya tenía que
dirigirme no sabía precisamente haciendo
que en que como campo no sabía si quería
escribir pero sabía que en mi vida iba a
haber libros o quería yo crecer estar
rodeada y ser feliz por siempre con los
libros cosa que más o menos no fue tan
verdad porque la cualidad más importante
de los libros es el poder que tienen
sobre nosotros entonces si nos pueden
hacer sentir feliz pero también tristes
nos pueden meter unas depresiones muy
densas nos pueden hacer reír hacer
llorar nos quitan el sueño entonces más
o menos encontramos nuestro camino nos
abrazamos y seguimos avanzando juntos a
mí también me tocó que después de todo
eso de saber que los libros iban a estar
en mi vida medio inventé mi trabajo y
digo medio porque soy promotora de
lectura principalmente
y haces de los oficios más antiguos en
la historia todos los que somos lectores
en realidad somos promotores de lectura
tales no frente a un público de
desconocidos pero en nuestros círculos
directos con nuestra familia con
nuestros amigos que no nos callamos
decir es que tienes que leer el libro
eso es ir promoviendo la lectura y es
algo muy valioso es muy importante
dentro de nuestro proceso de leer
compartir estas lecturas la parte que me
dio inventé fue el medio yo encontré en
internet en youtube un espacio donde
podía conectar con todas estas personas
que así como yo estaban hambrientas de
encontrar historias nuevas autores poder
hablar crear amistades a base de leer
entonces yo fui muy afortunada con eso y
siete años después sigo hablando
en los libros y voy como evangelizando
con la palabra del señor nuestro dios
víctor hugo entonces eso seguimos ahí
los libros y yo tomo formas raras y
diferentes pero seguimos ahí
y en mi camino lector me pasó
y ver un fenómeno una vez tras otra el
mismo fenómeno una vez que me vuelvo
promotora de lectura esto solo vino a
confirmar me que este fenómeno sucede en
todas partes y es que hay un grupo
selecto de lectores que le gusta mucho
decir y en esta creencia en que todo lo
que leen los jóvenes es basura entre
comillas para que nadie me lo cite
porque yo no soy de ese grupo
y estos son dos generalizaciones
terribles reglamente ignorantes en mi
opinión
que una de ellas es que pensar que toda
una generación de lo mismo y la segunda
es que todo lo que no me gusta a mí es
malo y no sirve
si yo pudiera
definir a los lectores como tres
categorías tres tipos de lectores pienso
que existe el lector que es niño que lee
con ilusión de crecer de tener sueños
nuevos de encontrar personajes y
aventuras de mucho con el corazón y
luego está el lector que ese adulto que
tal vez lee un poco más con el cerebro
quiere entender aprender quiere es muy
dado a rescatar cosas que los libros les
dejen cosas que les va a servir en su
vida no son tanto las ilusiones como que
se nos olvidan y la tercera la más
importante para mí en los jóvenes el
lector joven es un punto medio entre
estos dos todavía se acuerda acumular
con el corazón y con el cerebro también
le con el con el intelecto y trata de
encontrar libros que le dejen cosas pero
también quiere emocionarse y quiere que
los libros le hagan sentir cosas no sólo
que le den
revelaciones pues y la cosa aquí es que
a los que nos gusta leer a los lectores
queremos leer y nos gusta porque
queremos entender queremos entender el
resto del mundo queremos entender como
suceden las cosas pero queremos entender
no queremos darle palabras los
sentimientos extraños que tenemos
entonces el lector joven que empieza su
camino lector en la juventud es súper
valioso porque la juventud es ese
momento en nuestra vida que nos
cuestionamos todo hay un porqué detrás
de todas las explicaciones que nos dan
de todas las instrucciones que nos dan
no importa que tan pequeña fue tu etapa
rebelde está en la naturaleza la
naturaleza del joven es mover cosas
adentro
dentro de esta chamba y mentada que sí
existe bla bla que tengo
a la gente que no le gusta leer me
preguntan oye pero es que como se hace
un lector y la verdad más ninguna
respuesta nueva me gustaría decirles que
hay un suero que me pueden comprar que a
la vuelta le ponen tres gotitas del agua
y en una semana en don quijote así pero
no lo hay realmente yo creo fielmente
que el lector no se hace nace con esto
prefiero que lo comparo un poco con el
gen de mutación de los x-men ok en
witney donde en la diferencia aquí es
que todos yo considero que todos los
humanos nacemos con ese gen de mutación
en nosotros algunos lo tenemos desde muy
chiquititos con nuestros papás
leyéndonos antes de dormir casi creo que
sientes que toda la vida tuviste este
gen despierto de amor a la lectura y
otros la mayoría yo incluida y
necesitamos cuál deadpool un detonador
necesitamos alguien que lo despierte
algo que suceda no y cuál es el
detonador del amor por los libros es el
libro indicado en el momento indicado
es un poco ambiguo decirlo así pero en
la realidad el libro
[Música]
el amor a la lectura también puede ser
como el amor a primera vista o sea no lo
esperas y va a suceder y ya quedó
entonces qué sucede con con con esto de
detener tu camino el lector del libro
indicado en el momento indicado para que
todo pueda despertar quiere decir que si
no estás disfrutando tu libro el que
estás intentando leer y lo voy a
terminar y lo quiero terminar para poder
decir que lo termine déjalo ir no es el
momento tal vez ese momento ya pasó tal
vez a veces me toca a mí que estoy
leyendo un libro y digo esto me ha
gustado tanto hace tres años porque hace
tres años era una persona diferente hace
seis meses yo era una persona diferente
y muchas veces cuando somos muy
afortunados es un libro que nos va a
gustar que es para un momento en el
futuro que vamos a llegar a ese punto de
que vamos a poder disfrutar disfrutar un
libro no es lo mismo que te guste un
libro te puede puedes odiar el libro
pero lo disfrutas también eso es también
como para echarme otra te toque
diferente sobre el tema
y la segunda pregunta del millón que me
hacen además de
cómo se hace un lector es cómo se hace
un lector snow que dice que la
literatura juvenil es basura yo creo que
la manera más fácil de tratar de
entenderlo porque como yo no pertenezco
a ese grupo tampoco como entiendo
también es que como que el profesor x
les borra el disco duro y les dice así
que tú te fuiste lector toda tu vida
entonces como que ellos se creen
quiksilver no y así de que yo en la
universidad leí el ulises de james joyce
y no entendí todo lo que así
james joyce estuviera sentado aquí con
nosotros él fue el serial primero decir
no
y la verdad es que como que a ellos se
les olvida que leer es como querer
correr un maratón querer desarrollar ese
amor por los libros es como echarte un
maratón
si no corremos si no hacemos ejercicio
pero dices tengo que correr un maratón
antes de morir
no puedes inscribirte en la siguiente
semana y correr y querer no desmayar te
en el primer kilómetro y tienes que
prepararte salir a caminar luego correr
a lo mejor haces medio maratón después
haces un maratón completo y así te pones
pues muy salsa se saca el triatlón y el
ironman pero como que muchas veces este
grupo selecto de personas de lectores
como que se les olvida que hubo un punto
en su vida donde también tuvieron que
aprender a no solo correr sino caminar
y muchas veces sucede son los críticos
literarios que es la crítica
los primeros en destrozar a los
contemporáneos destrozar a todo lo que
sucede aquí también se les olvida que
para aprender a correr caminar y caminar
en el mundo lector es empezar a leer
libros que son más sencillos para que tú
te conectes con ellos el libro es el
espejo de erice de potter donde ves
todas tus emociones ahí te regresa todo
lo que deseas es un espejo de pasiones
humanas y muchas veces es más sencillo
empezar poco a poco el libro medio
contemporáneo tal vez un clásico
infantil tal vez ese cuento de poe que
todo el mundo te dice que está bien sido
ya puesto quita el sueño dos noches pero
de modo así más poquito a poquito
avanzando hacia poder ya que él me
perdone leer 'los miserables' no
directamente entrar así
no funciona así entonces a los críticos
se les olvida eso y son son muy dados a
que les digo este libro contemporáneo
nuevo son los primeros en acusar a los
peros que han sufrido bastante entre
ellos por ejemplo cuando cortázar
publica rayuela híjole la verdad este
asiento hasta ciento gancho y ahorita
publica rayuela y una de sus críticas
más fuertes fue citó tampoco me lo
atribuye
si la imitación y el plagio fueran
virtudes
julio cortázar es un gran escritor
wayne sábado se hace a mí me dicen eso a
nivel algo y me muero y mismo me llevan
al hospital o sea me da algo y más un
libro como rayuela que está diseñado en
múltiples formas donde puedes tener una
experiencia
leyéndolo y después una completamente
diferente porque literal el autor diseño
que tú puedas a cada van der sar hacer
lo que puse te antoje entonces cine para
cortas a no sé cómo no le dio algo y
cayó en el hospital
y qué pasó pues pasó algo que ha
sucedido miles de veces en la historia
de la literatura que es que fueron los
chavos los jóvenes que leyeron a
cortázar leyeron rayuela y ese fue el
libro indicado encontraron el espejo se
vieron reflejados ahí y el problema con
esto para aquellos que no creen en el
libro indicado momento indicado es que
yo estoy segura que de haber sido
cualquier otro libro en ese momento para
estos chavos
cual aleteo de mariposa su vida lector a
su camino lector hubiera cambiado
completamente me atrevo a decir que
muchos de esos lectores que estaban
leyendo el libro juvenil best-seller de
su momento
rayuela
no tendrían tal vez nunca verían
hubieran despertado el gen mutante
lector
entonces los lectores jóvenes es por eso
que somos muy afortunados que tenemos
esas capacidades para dar vueltas al
mundo o sea moldearlo podemos hacer
revoluciones afuera allá afuera en el
mundo que se necesitan y son importantes
pero también aquí adentro cuando estamos
jóvenes podemos tenemos el valor de
abrir nuestro corazón a primeras
oportunidades de abrir nuestro corazón a
intentar cosas sin miedo y por si no
rompe el corazón conmover pero sé que
creemos que es el fin del mundo pero no
pasa nada todo sigue y somos capaces los
jóvenes lectores son capaces de
deshacerse de su ego y de tomar el libro
bestseller del momento y permitirle no
solo la oportunidad de que tal vez te
cambia la vida a ti lector sino aún más
valioso tú cambiarlo el camino al libro
cortázar fue abrazado por miles de
jóvenes latinoamericanos
que gracias a ellos hoy podemos
encontrar rayuela en todas las librerías
en todas las bibliotecas y lo
reconocemos como el gran texto que es se
ha convertido un clásico más y ahí está
esperándonos a que sea el momento
indicado para ayudarnos a correr
entonces ármense de valor arm ese valor
lo gritan no critican las lecturas
jóvenes y que tengan felices maratones y
después venir a mi texto
[Aplausos]